[Music]
the periodic table put forth by
Mendeleev was quite well defined but it
wasn't the best table ever why do I say
so
it's because with time the number of
elements being discovered increased and
fitting them into the table according to
the periodic law by Mendeleev seemed
difficult also we have taken a look at
the major limitations of the periodic
table by Mendeleev so with all these
limitations how do we study the elements
how do we carry out the periodic
classification well if the elements
discovered later did not follow the
periodic law given by Mendeleev then the
only way to arrange them was by
modifying the law yes this was however
not what scientists could think of as
the first step it was quite gradually
that the scientists realized the fact
that the law could be modified but how
did this happen it was around 1913 that
the British physicist Henry Moseley
found an interesting fact he realized
that instead of atomic mass all the
elements will show periodicity if
arranged on the basis of the atomic
numbers wait a second did I just say
atomic number isn't atomic number a
randomly assigned number to the atom by
us actually not atomic number of any
element is never a randomly assigned
number it is basically the number of
protons present in the nucleus of the
atom of that element for instance let us
consider the first four elements in the
table so we get atomic numbers of
hydrogen as one helium as two lithium as
three and beryllium as four so why are
these elements assigned these particular
atomic numbers only can be changed these
numbers ever no we can't that is because
they have these respective numbers of
protons in their nuclei hydrogen has
just one proton in its nucleus
similarly helium has two and lithium has
three and how many protons will Beryl
has correct it has four protons the same
is valid for other elements as well
coming back to the table did Henry
Moseley think that characteristics of
elements are based on their atomic
numbers and not the atomic masses yes
that's what he meant and with this there
emerged a new law of studying the
periodicity of elements it was called
the modern periodic law
the law stated that the properties of
elements are periodic functions of
atomic numbers so what does this mean
this means that the physical and
chemical properties of elements do occur
periodically but this happens when the
elements are arranged according to their
atomic numbers all the known elements
could be arranged based on their atomic
numbers with this predicting the
properties of elements yet to be
discovered but simpler and more precise
this helped in placing the newly
discovered elements properly in the
periodic table also overcoming the
limitations of Mendeleev stable was
another advantage and how did that
happen do you remember their limitations
the first limitation of no precise
position for hydrogen was mainly
overcome it was assigned a position that
would not lead to any confusion we will
take a detailed look at this position of
hydrogen later in the higher grades next
limitation of the Mendeleev stable was
the position of isotopes can you
recollect what isotopes are yes they are
the atoms of the same element with
different number of neutrons that is the
reason why in spite of belonging to the
same element the atoms have different
atomic masses because atomic mass is the
sum total of all the protons and
neutrons present in the nucleus placing
isotopes in the table was a limitation
but as we know in the modern periodic
table the position of elements was no
longer based on atomic masses they were
based on atomic numbers an atomic number
is given by the number of protons that
means
a different number of neutrons will not
be a worry for us so it was possible to
place the isotopes now because all the
isotopes of any particular element could
be placed at one single place and this
place would be the position of that
element in the table so now can we say
that chlorine-35 and chlorine-37 will be
placed together they both have 17
protons which means they will have the
same atomic number hence they will be
placed together lastly we have the
prediction and placement of undiscovered
elements the previous table by Mendeleev
was based on atomic masses of elements
however the atomic masses of elements
were not arranged in a constantly
increasing order hence if newly
discovered elements were to be placed in
the table then their position would be
confusing but why it's simply because if
the atomic masses of previously
discovered elements were not in a
regularly increasing manner then how and
where will be placed the new ones just
for the sake of understanding let us
assume some values for the atomic masses
of two elements element one has atomic
mass three hundred whose position comes
first
while element two has an atomic mass 297
which is placed later in the table that
is after element one now in this case if
a newly discovered element the element
three has atomic mass of 299 where will
we place it between the two elements or
after the second element with atomic
mass 297 and this is what was happening
with mental layoffs periodic table
because the atomic masses of elements
were not placed in a constantly
increasing manner some elements did have
atomic masses less than the previously
placed element so placing the newly
discovered elements will disturb the
entire table but in the modern periodic
table the position of elements was based
on atomic numbers so newly discovered
elements could be easily added in
between because the atomic numbers of
are found to occur in a constantly
increasing manner this is how the
important limitation of mental layoffs
periodic table but ruled out and that is
the reason why the new periodic table
surfaced as the most useful tool for
studying elements the newly arranged
table of elements was based on the
modified law do you remember the name of
this important law yes it is the modern
periodic law so can you guess the name
of the table that was based on the SLO
yes it was called the modern periodic
table now let's have a detailed look at
this modern periodic table its
properties and a few of its important
characteristics in the upcoming videos
[Music]
you